thank you
[Music]
Nick it's your lucky day dude there's so
many articles that are just right up
your alley I don't like when I'm here
across hairs you know that I wish I care
for you man you're just you're just
ending up in the line I walk into this
this dude his name's Thomas Martell he's
22 years old he lives in Chicago with
his mom and some cats
he lives with his mom at 22. sure does
pretty common I think is a mom like a
cat lady that has like 22 cats she has
she's [__] his mama drinking cat milk
honestly these stories you've been
setting us up [__] crazy they've been
nuts today I know and they own a Chicago
pizza store or something you get myself
to read something like that you keep
setting up your hand off your chest bro
I don't like that lord it's fake out
rain man I want some pizza now what the
[__] yeah where did that come from
Cosmopolitan Las Vegas
the Chicago pizza store I like the deep
dish okay like that deep pie okay yeah
that's nice yeah what's your favorite
pizza Geo yeah you want to go around
after watching Home Alone I really
really always crave
um uh cheese pizza just cheese yeah
sometimes it hits it goes here just by
itself yeah
because you forget how good cheese is
because you you get the other toppings
and it kind of overpower overpowers you
do extra cheese yeah but then you get it
and you go back to regular cheese you're
like oh [__] this is good by itself
especially when you think of like the
Ninja Turtles movie intro when
everyone's eating pizza whether the
cheese poles that pizza shop next to the
martial arts store and and like [__]
Westminster or something
when you pull it the cheese string that
that keeps the party cheese oh yeah this
is the cartoons they pull like that I
love that you guys are hungry because
this is gonna be very good oh no wait
the mom died and the cats and the kid
was eating the mom and I'm ordering
pizza
something even even better so uh this
guy 22 year old Thomas Martell Ryan's
evil huh he would repeatedly kill and
replace the kittens with exact
look-alikes
yesterday so his mom wouldn't find out
that he was killing dismembering
drowning or microwaving multiple kittens
signs of a serial killer they always
start with [__] Psychopaths yeah
apparently he's been doing this since he
was eight oh my God throw his ass in
jail right now dude you don't you don't
smell dead cats in your house he turned
himself in
he turned himself in why because he's
like I have a problem no his girlfriend
ratted him out and then he turned
himself in this guy has a girlfriend
with girlfriends too hey dude a lot of
psychopaths have girlfriends like
telling me this guy Jeffrey this guy
would have a girlfriend look at him hey
it's good looking dude you know what's
funny he's like you look at his eyes
you're like nothing there he looks like
the guy that uh beat Rodney King Jesus
do you guys think that everybody
remembers that guy do you guys think
Psychopaths should be able to walk
around in society yeah there's a lot
there's a lot like they I actually Walk
Among Us there's like I think one out of
five men have psychopath tendencies
[__] comments
say like type it like [__]
probability of psychopath in men
it's like a [__] what country
World wow homie what yeah did you say
wear a wire worldwide
1 1.2 of U.S adult men okay that's not
one in five that's one in a hundred
let's do a lot Psychopathic statistics
right here you should still assume it's
one in five but it says a psychopath
would read that as one in five
well one out of a hundred still a high
probability yeah throwing like a [__]
train or some [__] or on a plane it says
one out of a hundred yeah but then but
but they said that the the
traits that that you have it's not
always expressed in murder and killing
you're being like skills right and
things like that could be in your
fashion they uh they said that uh a lot
of um
a lot of uh uh high stress sales or like
um oh yeah like CEOs yeah yeah yeah
um extreme sports special ops guys yeah
uh like the they they were saying that
the the you know like those rock
climbers it's it's basically like
adrenaline High it does Stakes it
doesn't determine that you are going to
be a killer but you don't have the
ability to register the same sensitivity
that most people do or like so for
example right like let's say you don't
have the same fear
things so then you can do crazy rock
climbing without like uh with a cable
because you're just it's nothing and
then you require a lot of stimulation to
feel certain things so then the dark
side of it is you start killing [__]
because then you get the the jollies
from crazy [__]
yeah so he's 22 you said yep and he's
been doing it since he was eight all
these kittens dude he just keeps like
killing them and then finding exact like
look legs and replace it you think he
thought about killing humans dude for
sure you think I think that's next on
the agenda yeah you think he do you
think he dabbled a little bit you think
he got close to pulling the trigger
maybe you did it yeah you didn't put
some medicine in his mom's drink and
then she goes nah it's too much too much
too much I bet you would keep like
killing the kittens like in different
ways like yeah that's her horrendous man
that's his Hobby
that's what his video games are and I
guess he eventually got like his
girlfriend caught on to it because he
would dump the cat he put the kittens in
like a bag and just launched into the
like the river or like a trash shoot and
then one of her friends saw him doing it
and recorded him sent it to his girl and
was like
is he throwing a cat away like and then
she was like is he buying cat-shaped
back I don't know there's a cat I think
certain bags they take on a cat shape
it's very clear oh and so he he started
to like and and this the girl like if
you actually read the real story it's a
little weird because the the girlfriend
witnessed so many times that he did it
but like I guess she wasn't catching on
um well because who would have thought
well because like he would who would
have thought that that's a cat in that
bag well he would say that um he was
gonna give the cat a bath and that the
cat or he would teach the cat to swim so
you bring the cat into the building and
underwater you could always just come
back out and go the cat didn't make it
cat died and then she's like the cat
like multiple times
oh okay if that happens three times
that exact thing happened I think three
or more times so she didn't really catch
on until maybe she's like maybe cats
aren't good at swimming she would not
only go with him to buy the new cash he
would pay for it sometimes
well she was she got wrapped it is he
because is it because is it because he's
all like the chef Mosaic yeah
smart no because he learned that
so so she's basically like damn we got
to keep buying these cats for his mom
because he keeps because cats aren't
cheap no
like kittens oh yeah this is a highly
affordable if he is a psychopath he he
probably picked someone that was so
naive and easy yeah like he's not gonna
get
again he was eight I'm sure he already
has all the outs and Mastermind yeah
yeah like he already knows what to say
the mom never caught on like the mom was
never like it smells funny here well
that um the girlfriend did because he I
think one of the times that he killed
the cat he just put in a bag and stuck
it in the pantry oh and she was like
something in there is rotten and it was
the cat in the bag
dude
imagine microwaving a cat dude yeah uh
so wait so the cat is in the pantry and
she was never like red flag
you know what I mean like I understand
if the milk was in the pantry sometimes
we have so much [__] in our head that's
all I'm saying she might have some
Mosaic yeah something tells me when when
you're like a kid like this you kind of
have a mom that's a little dense
that's probably like you get away with
that [__] you're not doing anything you
want to kind of like not recognize it
you know sneak around your mom yeah or
the mom has a little bit of it in
herself yeah maybe Mom has mosaics we
need to think about that wait so the mom
was questioning it are you talking about
the girlfriend is is like the mom is
never questioned okay so but the
girlfriend saw the pantry stuff because
we saw pretty much that's where cereal
goes she pretty much seriously half a
dozen or more obvious signs that he was
doing this it's not like but is it like
she's like in retrospect like after she
sees the video it's like oh those
moments and then she's like all the
memories because she's too stupid she
bought multiple cats with them you know
but love is blind guys Real Love is
Blind I'm telling you he he chose his
victim or like he he picked her because
she's easy you know what I mean like and
she was next bruh
she might have been
but I mean what's this was it Jeffrey
Dahmer he never killed his wife he just
killed other women
well then her friends was next or dudes
right
oh wait not dahlmer the other one Bundy
Bondi Bundy because he had a wife a
girlfriend she had no [__] idea but
then every time they got into an
argument he would go and kill a girl
but he was way more um
not Charming people said he was Charming
I don't think he was that true but he
was way more like Incognito than this
[__] guy dude yeah he was um so the
thing too is that she said that every
time they would buy a new cat like he
would name it the same name so it's like
come on
come on girl but I feel like this is the
Gateway right it's kind of good that
he's going now because then he turned
himself in yeah but he's gonna he's
gonna get let out and then he's still
gonna do something because yeah none of
the crimes are that crazy it's just cats
right in some country in some states
it's so illegal to torture or kill yeah
you're not killing her you're not
killing a human being so he maybe gets
let out in five or ten years
you said he's 17. his bail is set up 75
000. bro he's been killing cast since he
was eight let's do the math here but the
the crazy thing is they can't really
quantify the cat number because it's at
least like six or seven but they can't
really prove it because like well if
he's a psychopath you just gotta trick
him into saying it right he's like oh I
bet you only killed like 30 goals do I
get him the 45 you're gonna poke at his
narcissism
you wanna know something crazy I feel
like I almost had this [__] yeah
it's kind of spooky let's talk about it
when I was one of my earliest memories
when I was four uh I was in the
Philippines and I was swinging a cat
around that I found by the tail yeah I
was just like swinging it and then like
all these like family members and stuff
they like crowded around me and they
were like never do this ever and they
made it like such a big ass deal that I
was like okay holy [__] this is bad yeah
whoa okay I didn't know it was bad I
really didn't know it was bad I just saw
a cat out in the street like a alley
cat's okay but then but then the guy who
went out with scissors and cut off the
eyes
my cousin made me do it no but like I
think that because they all knew my
family knows that that's a sign of like
you're gonna turn into a [__] psycho
so they really like hammered it to my
head and like punished me really bad for
that but that was like the first
interaction I ever had with like a
random animal I wonder if that is a
nurture moment like you know like all
kids they have it and then I depending
on like how your environment is it
shapes you into becoming more of that or
not of that because tell me how to pluck
the Wings off of a fly
[Laughter]